[Musique] Les
Russes espionnent un satellite en train de prendre des photos
et Dieu sait ce qui nous amène là-haut
Harrison, nous ne pouvons pas justifier un
programme spatial qui ne met rien dans l'
espace, nous finirons tous au chômage
dans ce saut pilote, vous êtes les bienvenus pour
marcher 216  des kilomètres je vais m'asseoir à l'arrière
du bus nous mettons un humain dans l'
espace où nous l'amenons trop tôt
il brûle à la rentrée j'ai besoin de maths qui
n'existent pas encore trouver un mathématicien
avant que les Russes ne plantent un drapeau dessus  la
fichue lune vous avez une pièce d'identité à la
NASA, monsieur,
je ne savais pas qu'ils avaient entendu pas mal de
femmes travailler dans le programme spatial
vous n'êtes pas différent de la vérité de l'espace a
besoin d'un ordinateur Catherine après cela,
elle peut gérer les numéros gagnants que vous mettez
dans le boom n'a jamais eu  une personne de couleur ici mais
ne m'embarrasse pas c'était un vide
la nuit dernière je suis désolé je ne suis pas néerlandais tu
devrais être ingénieur je suis une femme noire
je ne vais pas envisager l'impossible
je me tiens sous un  vaisseau spatial nous
vivons l'impossible le
traitement de données IBM  ng système nous savons comment
programmer
Oh Jerrica c'est John Glenn que faites-vous
mesdames pour la NASA calculer votre
trajectoire nous ne pouvons aller nulle part sans
les chiffres comment pourriez-vous être moche les genoux
larges mec c'est égal j'ai le
droit de voir de la graisse  et la
NASA éthique ne commande pas de femmes pour le
programme d'ingénieur chaque fois que nous avons une
chance d'aller de l'avant
J'aimerais assister au briefing d'aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas de protocole pour les femmes présentes
elles déplacent la ligne d'arrivée vous devriez toutes
être reconnaissantes de l'avoir coupée  Je
ne sais même pas si je peux suivre dans cette
pièce tu es meilleur avec les chiffres que
n'importe qui dans cette capitale
tu es parti depuis 300 heures je n'aime pas
ça moi aussi
allemand partout j'ai besoin que tu sois où
diable allez-vous tous les jours la
salle de bain colorée est à un mile nous arrivons tous
au sommet ensemble nous n'y arrivons pas du
tout plus de 50 millions de personnes
regardent cette perte John l'IBM
obligeons les filles à vérifier les
connaissances  mes filles sont re  ady nous devons
faire le travail
Colonel Glenn c'est bon de savoir que la NASA
n'a pas abandonné le bon
cerveau à l'ancienne l'amitié sept a
connu une sorte de dysfonctionnement
il y a une vraie boule de feu dehors il
fait un peu chaud ici à cause du
combat  de nos vies gens amitié 7
copiez-vous
[Musique]